what have been some of the repercussions
of you defecting have you ever been
threatened or has there been
intelligence surveillance ever done on
you or anything like that
well i mean we're gonna even begin uh
when i spoke out uh south korea of
course intelligence informed me that i
um i'm on the killing list of kim
jong-un
and kim jong-un's killing list is not a
joke right if you want to kill somebody
he's gonna kill somebody so
it was it was good of a south korean
intelligence informed me that so i
appreciate it
but i mean we know that no country gonna
protect me if he don't only kill me he's
gonna go ahead and do it and there's of
course no prequel with precaution for
doing that
uh not only that though i expected that
to happen but
of course because i spoke out everybody
that i left behind the three generations
of my family
and even including my neighbors
had denounced me on youtube the north
koreans should have the propaganda
channel announcing that i'm the puppet
of of the west propaganda of the west
and this is all the bizarre thing about
youtube is talking about the fake thing
and the censoring people they send my
videos but they do not answer the video
made by the north korean dictatorship
it is hilarious
user can see that video and then all my
families are gone afterwards and i don't
know if they've been executed or sent to
produce in camps
of course after that north korea had a
smear campaign against me creating north
korea another way of their making money
is through hacking did you hear that how
many became bitcoin they store
and how many uh hackers they raised so
they attacked even the uk health
insurance companies they have done it of
course they they do hackers they create
so many smear campaign against me
so that's what they they're good at the
character assassination
so what did that i was gonna say what
what were the accusations about your
character
so it was that i'm a cia spy so i get
paid from the cia and saying lies and
then i uh light north korea has no
starvation is the best country on earth
and everything is good but she's trying
to become a sensational saying that
there's a poverty there's oppression and
the lying about means that
the worst thing that came up was that i
was very individualistic and ambitious
as a young girl
in north korea being ambitious and
individualistic is like the worst thing
can be right so on the video they say
she was the poisonous mushroom that grew
up in a pile of trash so she was younger
so ambitious and so individualistic
and in the world like that thing is
embraced here
and of course
another thing they they make a problem
is that i said i
climbed the mountain before my escape to
cross the river but they went to google
maps and google
that they measured the altitude of the
mountain but then the altitude and
mountain it was high here
but as a young girl how do i know what
altitude do you call that here or
mountain i still don't know oh so they
used a discrepancy in how high the hill
was
versus a mountain
to discredit whether or not you would
lived in the place that you live so what
was the implication of that you were
never in north korea
no no no thank god north korea comes
before then there's you know a lot of
sympathizers of the communist party so
they were saying they went to google map
and checked and then what she climbed
was not here i mean it was in the
mountain it was here
and then nurse then eventually they say
why does she even speak english she's
not like north korean she's a fake
person like pretending to be north
korean but thank god north korea
released my birth certificate
and they really released my father's
birth certificate they released my
father's sentences to labor camp
and my mom's like entire record so i am
confirmed north korean thank god but the
sympathizers are idiots asking me so
what's your password show me your
password how do i know that you're north
korean so i'm like if i have a passport
why would i even escape
i would have flew here right why would i
even close a coffee desert
so this is how dumb
the world is i just cannot even fathom
but thankfully north korea confirmed
that my name is yummy park i was born in
this year that day
and you're on the kill list
exactly so
they did way more good to me than bad
because in america i mean i don't know
in the west people really sympathize
north korea and hate america
and north korea is the enemy of america
therefore they love north korea
so i became the target from the marxist
leninist maoists communists
and of course like
anti-western people everybody
and and now i'm the enemy of the work
so
i have a lot of enemies there's a big
list you're on everyone's kill list
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace